a qué atribuye esta nueva ola de
violencia en israel
debido principalmente a dos razones la
primera y la más importante
israel ha tenido contacto incluso un
congreso muy exitoso con países
musulmanes para hacer frente a la
amenaza iraní se llevó a cabo en el sur
de israel y eso ha enojado a los
palestinos que sienten que su tema que
el tema del problema palestino ha sido
borrado de la agenda debido a que a que
israel se integra al medio oriente eso
la forma de salir de ese estancamiento
es justamente haciendo acciones como
estas y lo segundo es que estamos en el
media ramadán y el medio de ramadán
sirve para una enorme incitación
religiosa a los fieles musulmanes
bueno y pues justamente el primer
ministro israelí naftalí bennett subrayó
hoy que israel no tendrá límites en la
guerra contra el terrorismo aseguró que
todos los que intenten atacar van a
pagar un alto precio como se pueden
interpretar estas afirmaciones
más que nada para uso interno una
intento del primer ministro de que la
población civil se sienta un poco más
segura como se podría llegar a traducir
a algún tipo de activismo militar
israelí es una invasión terrestre
moderada a las ciudades desde donde
salen los principales terroristas por
ejemplo la posibilidad que el ejército
israelí entra yenín donde salieron dos
terroristas de los cuatro atentados que
vivimos en las últimas dos semanas